hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become hello and welcome back to
another workout session so a lot of us
ladies we tend to be really
self-conscious about the fat around our
hips some of us call this even love
handles some of you called call it the
hip dip there are exercises which can
help to tone up on our hip area as well
as to lose the fats from this area okay
so this workout would get you twisted
because we will be doing a lot of
twisting movement to work on our
obliques as well as our hips each
workout will be for 30 seconds long and
we will move on to the next workout
without any break so try to keep up with
me as I explain each workout okay there
will be eight exercises so get ready
start by standing shoulder-width apart
as the first workout is going to be on
your toes is going to be a high knee
twist so what I want to do is place both
arms by the side of a head and as you
come up crunch and bring your elbow to
your knee okay ready let's go elbow to
knee elbow to knee and start twisting
your waist we're going to work on your
obliques as well as your hips that's the
focus and remember it's not just about
lying down doing crunches it's not just
that it's also about working on your
entire body so for this first workout we
want to focus on a total body movement
and the second workout will be a reverse
lunge with rotation so let's stand in
front as you reverse lunge rotate to one
side step back rotate to the opposite
side okay left leg back rotate to your
right right leg back rotate to your left
good hands in front of you rotate step
back and rotate good twisting finding
your balance and your core strength
twist step forward step back twist
nice keep going and twist and the next
workout get down onto your mat in a
scissor crunch position so get dunk
what I wanted to do is if you can lift
both legs up give me a cross punch okay
so it's a seated twist with punches if
this is too tough rest your heels on the
floor and punch left to right as you
twist okay to challenge yourself leave
both heels up twist and rotate left to
right very good
and the next workout is going to be a
bear crunch so get up get onto all fours
lift your knees off slightly as you
rotate and twist bring your elbow to the
opposite knee back onto all fours and
twist that's it very good so twist knee
to elbow knee to elbow nice you have 10
more seconds and we want to go and get
into a reverse plank twist
try to keep up with me one more and now
get onto your bum get into a reverse
plank push yourself up left hand across
down push yourself up right hand cross
and twist lift your butt off squeeze
your gluts and twist rotate and twist
nice again twist and look the opposite
side feel the back part of the hips
especially with this workout as well as
your gluts back down one more down one
more and now get into a high plank
let's get into a cross playing okay so
right knee to left elbow left knee to
your right elbow cross play very nice
it's all about twisting and moving good
keep going ten seconds left and right
after this we're getting into my
favorite plank variation plank hip dip
alright now get into a low plank lift
your butt off dip to the left and to the
right
left to right left to right very good
second final workout okay you have one
more workout right after this it's going
to be a tea rotation and you will get a
short 30 seconds break nice twist rotate
whoa can you feel your hips can you feel
a Bleek's twist rotate and now turn up
Hey - hi play T rotation twist and now
the other side
good find your balance tighten your core
do not Pike your butt rotate into a side
long T good high plank
rotate back down find a workout strong
core strong arms strong shoulders suck
your belly in and breathe and good rest
it out 30 seconds if you need to grab
some water drink some water if not stand
right back up the first workout is going
to be a high knee twist okay you know
all the exercises 30 seconds for each
workout no rest in between
let's move swiftly into the next workout
as fast as we can all right
so hands by your side let's get into a
high plank high knee twist good rotate
squeeze aim to touch your elbow with
your knee okay that's your goal twist as
high as you can drive your knee up
squeeze and bring it back down keeping
your chest up okay this is wrong
do not do this high up twist and rotate
second workout reverse lunge with a
rotation keep going
one more and now run in front of a mat
reverse lunge
rotate to your right right leg back
rotate to your left left leg back rotate
your right and the same on the other
side good step back legs 90 degrees step
forward pushing up with your Hughes
and again guys smile and the more you
the better you paced breathing
the longer you will last through your
workout now stick that twist with
punches choose your option use off and
let's go cross punch just tighten your
core suck on your lower abs tighten your
belly find your balance
sit on your body and twist and rotate
cross punches good rotate and rotate and
we're moving on to bear crunch okay so
get onto all fours immediately let's go
until all fours knees off rotate again
knee to elbow if you have not twisted
this often in your life right at the end
of this workout trust me you've done
lots of twisting and keep rotating good
elbow to the opposite knee and we're
moving on to reverse plank with a twist
as well let's go back down onto your
butt on your heels lift off left across
right hand across left across and
squeeze your gluts right at the top as
high as you can twist as far and reach
as far as you can feel your waist your
obliques working twist last two more and
we're moving on to cross plank all right
in a high plank position right to left
cross over good for this workout don't
have to rush it really feel the crunch
good cross crunch keeping your back flat
okay good
and immediately after this who are
getting into a low plank all right
plank hip dip all right now get into a
low plank let's move from side to side
so your left dip to your right and to
your left
breathe I can see my sweat oh whoa
absolutely burning my core my obliques
everything is on fire right now let me
know if your car is on fire be sure to
give this workout a thumbs up okay and
we're ending with TT rotation so into a
high plank rotate long nice t good back
down rotate and up and up good slow it
down if you need to find your balance
okay engage your core throughout that is
the whole point of these exercises is to
engage your core to rock and you are
done high five eight minutes of oblique
exercises we're twisting from left to
right right to left constantly moving to
be working on your obliques as well as
your hips so do this workout with your
total body strength training as well as
cardio exercises and trust me you will
see results okay you will see that your
hip area will get stronger you will find
better balance in your core and you will
also talk tone up and slim down on your
waist area if you like this workout if
you could keep up with me be sure to
give this video a thumbs up like this
video share this video with the
girlfriends get them twisting together
with you and be sure to subscribe to my
youtube channel and check out other
workout videos workout challenges
recipes as well as meal plans and I'll
see you next week
do you also check out my fitness app
called whew
the best